from waiting in the 9/11 Memorial pools
in New York City and removing dangerous
rocks halfway up the Niagara Falls
Cliffs to sanitizing the train cars of
Tokyo's renowned Metro System here's
everything we deep cleaned in
[Music]
20123 this is Jim he's cleaning the
reflecting pools at the 9/11 Memorial in
New York City Jim and his team are
working beneath a 27 ft tall waterfall
in near total darkness vacuuming every
inch of the pool their goal is to do it
without missing a spot it's a physically
demanding job but that's not the only
challenge I've never actually marked how
many miles it is but you do a few miles
in there and it could be humid and you
come out of there and uh it feel like
you walked on the moon
almost the pools are nearly an acre each
so it would take hours to finish the job
before the sun comes
up while he works inside the pool other
crew members work on the bronze panels
above
ground these routines happen 5 days a
week and are essential for keeping the
memorial in pristin condition for the
millions who come to pay their respects
here they start by shutting off the
waterfalls and over the next 8 hours Jim
and his team work tirelessly to deep
clean this
pool the hardest part is it's it's a
long test the pool is Big it's it's not
a uh a swimming pool you know it's a 200
by 200 Giant
pool I'm going to pull the hose out and
then bring it back or whatever just you
don't have to use the whole reel we have
too much hose we usually have three men
through the pool so two guys be in the
pool and one guy will be outside running
the the pumps which collect the uh
debris and return the clean water back
to the pool once we're set we're on our
way I go and vacuum generally and I I
have whoevers with me that night brushes
behind come on hurry up sorry we got all
day
here all right the vacuum will capture
most of the debris and the person
brushing will knock up some of the other
loose debris that doesn't get caught and
it will be C into like some of our
filters that we have running
downstairs now I'm trapped in the hose
here I'm going to trip
myself and we'll be on America's
Loopers the workers generally clean out
dirt leaves and algae from the bottom of
the pools they also remove larger items
that visitors drop or throw in they
don't always know what they'll encounter
in the pool each night we find kids toys
little small items depends on the the
crowd one night I actually found a a bat
in there and I'm not talking about a
baseball bat I'm talking about a bat it
was pretty wild when it flew away from
me when and I realized I was grabbing a
bat depending on the cleanliness of the
pool it could take any
between six and 7 hours and sometimes if
we feel up to it we could do it a little
quicker some people treat this place
like a uh wishing well so we do catch
some money and unfortunately I think
some people being that it's so far
removed from the original 911 I think
some people are a little uh uneducated
about this place and some people treat
it like just a regular Fountain and
they're throwing garbage in here
sometimes too you know people have to
learn that this isn't your uh Mall
fountain I knew few of the uh Brokers
that passed away a whole uh a whole
group of them had a meeting in one of
the towers unfortunately and uh except
for one one Traer all of them
perished I I think about them
often because we go up top where the
names are and brush near the name plates
the troughs and uh on the North side
they're all all on one panel so I see I
see their names just about every day
total waste of uh lives that you know
could have been doing good good in the
world
now while Jim and the team finished
cleaning the pools below Ryan is
tackling the bronze name panels above
the panels honor the
2,983 victims of the attacks on the
World Trade Center both in 1993 and 2001
Ryan will have to strip the top layer of
metal and use a blowtorch to remove a
carving someone etched onto the plaque
without damaging the rest of the
memorial this confuses me why you want
to write something
[Music]
here for a mark like that you have to go
pretty deep get all the way down
otherwise you can't really get rid of it
if you don't go down far enough you'll
see it when you refinish it the further
down you go the better sometimes I've
seen nice things written but you know
youday don't understand you just you
can't just write whatever you want on
it after briefly assessing the damage
Ryan needs to remove the protective bars
so he can reach the entire metal surface
to do this he props up the bars with a
wood Plank and unhooks the brackets
holding up the
panels now what I'll do is uh rub it
down with a NAFTA it's almost like a
paint thinner it just kind of takes the
wax off so I'm not burning
wax if I can open
it and it shouldn't take too long once I
get the torch on
it there's so much in the prep and then
the finishing the torch is
actually not that bad after sanding down
the top layer of panel and neutralizing
the wax Ryan is ready to blowtorch the
damaged area to melt the metal in the
patina so he can repaint the color layer
and restore the panel to its original
state this is what we
use and it's basically just a patina in
a
solution oh I haven't used you in a
while prep
them so I'm basically getting up up to
the right temperature if it's too cold
it it'll go on spotty if it's too hot
it'll kind of evaporate off or it'll get
burnt in the summer months the longest
part of the job is waiting for the
burned panel to cool before applying a
new layer of wax and an acrylic top coat
to finish the restoration
process we're going to put the acrylic
spray on
it just kind of like a clear coat helps
it kind of adhere a little bit better
the last step really well besides
buffing the wax off so I'm just going to
put the wax on real nice not too hard
not a lot you don't need a ton just put
it on
lightly the wax will go over the finish
and make it look once I polish it it'll
look brand new got a little bit of heat
but that's cuz it's still
hot but it was right here
now all Ryan has to do is buff off the
excess wax using a white scotchbrite pad
and then once it gets smooth you know
you're
done when people do something like that
I wouldn't say it makes me angry I get
it some of these people might not have
even been alive when it happened or they
were too young to get it my uncle was a
New York City firefighter and he was
hurt really bad here but uh luckily he
survived we got we got a little
lucky after a strenuous 6 to S hours of
cleaning Jim and the team are ready to
head out of the
pool by tomorrow morning a new batch of
visitors will see sparkling pools below
rushing waterfalls and most of them
won't know that Jim's team was even
here when we uh finished the pool most
of the time we just were just ready to
really get out of there and most of our
inspection you know we're fairly
confident that we did the proper job
there's always was a little fail Factor
but you know not too
bad my father worked in these buildings
almost his whole life and my father was
here for uh the 93 bombing and that was
before cell phones and everything and he
was the he was on the 30th floor of the
uh second tower when he was there he was
like the floor Marshal he came home full
of soot but he stayed there because
there was people people that couldn't
get down the steps so he made sure that
he stayed with them so I I think on 9/11
day you know if he was here uh we
probably would have lost him because he
wouldn't have left he passed away a
couple of years
ago he was always so proud of of the job
I I probably had chances to do other
things in this building but even if I
wanted to do another job I wouldn't
because of him and I and now you know I
I love doing it so I do
it next up we travel to Japan to see how
the Tokyo Metro keeps its reputation as
one of the cleanest Transportation
Systems in the
world this is takayuki a cleaning
supervisor at the rail yard in AOS he's
worked for Tokyo Metro for almost 41
years and it's his job to make sure the
trains are cleaned
thoroughly
the Tokyo Metro system is famous for
being one of the cleanest Subway systems
in the
world it transports an average of about
6 million people daily and maintaining
that reputation takes both an extensive
amount of operational organization and a
ton of manpower the cleaning staff's
approach is straightforward but
uncompromising whatever Tokyo Metro's
millions of daily passengers touch must
be cleaned today they're cleaning the
train cars at the ISA Rail Yard which
they do every 15 days the cleaners take
careful measures to ensure each nook and
cranny is cleaned then we'll head to the
ginai charmis station located in one of
the busiest shopping areas in Tokyo
Japan where they clean the station top
to bottom
there are 41 trains on the Tokyo Metro
Choda line the team cleans 3 to four
trains a day once a train comes into the
rail yard cleaners start by picking up
any Trash they
see it takes four workers to clean the
exterior it's all done by hand and
cleaners start by hosing it down with
water and then using brushes to scrub it
with
soap
for
if the stain does not come off with a
brush and soap then they use a pad to
scrub it
off next they rinse off all the
soap meanwhile other staffers clean the
interior it takes 10 workers and they
start at the top of the car and work
their way down to the
[Music]
bottom
the first step is to clean the area
where advertisements are placed then
they clean the luggage racks and then
the wall area they use rags and dusters
to clean each
part
cleaners then tackle the floors and
start by mopping they also use sticks to
clean crevices near the entrance of each
door twice a year they wax the floors of
each train car they remove all the old
wax with a polisher and then they let it
dry once it's dry they apply two Co of
wax it takes about an hour and a half
from the time the wax is removed to the
time the new wax
[Music]
dries alt together it takes workers a
little over an hour to clean the trains
inside and out once the cleaning is
complete the kuki begins his
inspection
once the kuki approves the cleaning the
trains return to service ready to
transport millions of passengers all
over
again inside the ginai CH station chako
and Kenji work to clean the station
daily Kazo has been working for Tokyo
Metro since he was 18 18 he got his
train license at 20 and drove trains
until he was 57 he leads the team
responsible for the cleaning and
security for this station and a few
others there are nine Tokyo Metro train
lines and 180 stations that provide
service to the greater Tokyo
area
the escalator handrails are a high touch
surface within the station and Chicago
takes Extra Care to wipe the belt with
wet washcloths she wides the escalators
up and down until they are all clean
escalator
Chicago is also responsible for the
dirtiest job of the day cleaning the two
restrooms in the ginai CH station the
main cleanings happen once a day she has
been doing this work for the past 10
years
the first thing Chicago does is check
for any large pieces of trash if there
are none she sets up a fan and leaves it
on throughout the cleaning process
efficiency is one of the key parts of
her job and the fan allows the bathroom
to dry quickly so as not to disrupt any
customers who may need to use
it
Chicago sticks the ozone machine hose
down the toilet and turns it
on then she scrubs each toilet by hand
to make sure it's clean clean for the
next
customer she also cleans the walls it's
important that she's using the right
tools for each space so as not to
cross-contaminate areas she uses a red
dust cloth to clean areas from the knees
down which is called the contamination
Zone and a green one for clean zones
which are areas above the knees such as
mirrors and
sinks
[Music]
for
Chicago is also responsible for cleaning
the barrier between the platform and the
train
doors the top part is cleaned daily
while the lower part is cleaned once a
week the staff makes sure the station
platforms and walkways are clean for
customers
they do cleanings with brooms every day
but they also use a machine to clean the
floors twice a month the machine works
by sprinkling water onto the floor
scrubbing with a brush and then
collecting the dirty water with a
squeegee this way there is no water left
behind and no slippery
floors Kenji also goes around daily with
a shoulder vacuum and manually vacuum
teems up any trash and dust he comes
across especially in hard to- reach
[Music]
areas Japan has a long history with
cleaning and cleanliness that persists
today see
[Music]
for
this is Rivers he's waiting through a
pool of waste beneath one of the largest
aquariums in the world Georgia
Aquarium it's a filthy job but that's
not the only challenge there's a lot of
waste to manage when this Basin is full
it can hold between 5 to 10,000 gallons
of poop that funnels here from the
aquarium's habitats and it's the
culmination of many routine cleaning
procedures that happen at the aquarium
each week without which the safety and
health of the animals would be at risk
by the the time rivers and his team's
work here is complete the waste water
from this Basin will be cleaned filtered
and reused as topof water for the
aquarium's largest exhibit ocean Voyager
and the cleaning cycle will begin again
but before Rivers can do his job several
other critical procedures have to happen
first every day specialized teams gear
up to clean the hundreds of exhibits at
the
aquarium one of the first you'll see
when you enter the aquarium
is the sea line exhibit which is home to
this guy Toby a
279 harbor seal before a team of divers
can begin cleaning his habitat Toby and
the other sea lines need to vacate their
pools staffers use this time to do their
weekly ws and if we're talking about
Dirty Jobs he just urinated on the scale
and now we got to clean it side effect
of the
job this pool it's all sea lion poop
it's all sea lion poop everything that
she's vacuuming from here is going into
that was Basin so whatever we do in here
LSS or life support team then has to
clean up from their end Megan Wade leads
the pinnipeds team to clean the decks
and assist the dive operations team as
they clean the pools before guests
arrive this space is home to 14 sea
liines and three harbor seals the sea
lines can eat 5% to 8% of their body
weight making the sea line exhibit one
of the dirtiest in the aquarium Arium
every single morning we come in first
thing and prepare their food and this is
restaurant quality fish they get
numerous species of fish about five
different species and every single
morning one or two people will come in
and inspect every single fish so we're
looking for missing eyes missing fins
gills scrapes Cuts anywhere where you're
going to see that can breed bacteria so
that fish automatically get sorted out
and we don't use it at all we weigh out
there their food into buckets and then
we'll look at it again one last time
before feeding it to the animals once a
week every Wednesday it's we day
Wednesday follow me this way we have our
blue scale right here and then where the
green is lit up is going to tell us how
much they weigh so each sea lion will
walk from their habitat down this
hallway we get their weight and then
they'll walk back to their
habitat after the sea lines are fed
weighed and out of the main spaces Megan
and the team start working on cleaning
the deck areas her team splits up
between the back pools and the main
Gallery where they detail every nook and
cranny as soon as you come in in the
morning you can usually smell uh that
they have been sleeping overnight we
have high up platforms that they like to
sleep on the rocks and when you're
sleeping and you don't get up to go to
the bathroom it all just sits there so
if we didn't clean every single day it
would be really stinky kind of an
ammonia smell also there's fecal matter
as well we are going to detail this
whole area it gets cleaned every single
day but we detail it once a week every
week three male sea lions in one male
harbor seal all slept out here last
night so it's probably going to be
pretty messy the chemicals that we use
are to really break up that oil that's
on the surface that the sea liines
secrete so it's just soap and water
and then we'll use some chlorohexidine
to disinfect the area
afterwards and then down here Gail has a
like a nice little hand brush and she's
actually doing one of the dirtiest jobs
she's cleaning the drains all of this is
going to always be hosed to a drain away
from the water the sea Lion's swim in
she's taking the grates Off cleaning
inside the drain so that everything
flows nicely each day that we clean
so the drains are part of the
detailing the removal of the net and
soaking that's part of the detailing sea
lions when they breathe sometimes shoot
snot out of their nose so a lot of times
in sea lion habitats you'll see brown
snot on the walls so we'll need to scrub
that off too my favorite part about
cleaning the deck is getting to net the
poop out of the water because I it just
so reinforcing when you do a good job
job and you get good at it so I just
love doing
it after Megan and the pinnipeds team
work on the main Gallery deck Alex Glick
and a team of divers work on everything
below deck at the sealine exhibit today
you're going to start in po two and then
do pool three this one's vacuuming and
uh floor scrubbing and then pool three
will be vacuuming Rock work and then a
final floor scrub so we do this dive on
a just normal scuba even though it's
only an 8T pool we still do scuba diving
so that you have freedom of
movement this is our vacuum hose they
actually plug this in in the water and
we have to make a radio call to our life
support system and they'll turn the
vacuum on so we drop the vacuum head in
the water with the hose attached to the
diver and then they will Prime the hose
to get all the air out of the line this
pool it's all sea lion poop you want to
get as much vacuumed up before you start
scrubbing the floor this scrubber is one
of the tools the divers use to
thoroughly clean everything under the
water a hose pumps water through the
engine which Powers the scrubber this
high- press water makes cleaning the
floors and walls much
easier the single scrubber has hard
bristles and is used for rock work while
the double brush scrubber is used to
clean the walls and painted surfaces
once she's done vacuuming I'll give this
to her and she will then clean the floor
and she's holding the trigger down and
she's just swimming back and forth doing
kind of like a lawn mower motion
cleaning one side to the next to get
every single inch of the
pool if she comes across an area that's
particularly dirty she might slow down
spend a little time on it to get up
whatever scum is on the bottom and then
move
on animal debris doesn't just settle on
the habitat's floors and surfaces it
also collects in grates and skimmer
boxes these outflows help manage waste
between routine cleanings by separating
animals from some of the debris in total
it takes Al and his team of divers
roughly an hour to complete their work
in both
pools on the other side of the aquarium
is ocean Voyager the largest Indoor
Aquatic exhibit in the United States it
holds
6.3 million gallons of water and is home
to whale sharks mantes and thousands of
other fish this space is largely
dependent on an advanced life support
and filtration system but but still
relies on teams for maintenance and
Hands-On cleaning in Ocean Voyager we
have two whale sharks there's usan which
is the larger whale shark and then
there's
tooco common misconception about whale
sharks would be that they're dangerous
the most intimidating thing is they're
just big they just are big and so like
if you're in the way you just got to
move they are not out to hurt you like
their throat is only the size of a
quarter they're very very do file
creatures and they just want to cruise
along we usually have four to eight
divers in our everyday maintenance dive
we clean the windows so we need our
suction cup we bring what we call a
diaper otherwise it's just looks like a
rag when we clean the acrylic windows
with that and then usually we're doing
hand scrubbing they are scrubbing off
the algae and they're kind of basically
wafting off all that sand substrate that
cakes on and falls over onto those rocks
all that stuff that can grow on there is
potentially harmful for all the fish so
the whole goal of cleaning and upkeeping
the exhibit isn't necessarily to keep it
pretty even though that is also very
beneficial to keep it pretty for the
guests but at the same time there is the
purpose of doing it for the health of
the exhibit this is a monster exhibit so
if we didn't do it every day it'd be
pretty much impossible to upkeep the
blitz Dives which are our night Dives
that's our essential deep
clean so it can be a couple hours long
just to get everything we can done we
can run up to four of those Armada
machines and clean different areas of
the
Exhibit while ocean Voyager is being
cleaned Caroline Murphy and the Aquarius
team are over at the river Scout Gallery
getting ready to dive into these three
freshwater tanks the smallest tanks
measure 4T tall by 3 ft deep and the
team spends 1 to two hours every week
cleaning the windows and maintaining the
underwater Gardens here so despite the
size of these tanks we actually do
manage to squeeze some people in there
what we are going to be doing is
something called hookah diving so the
divers are getting in very carefully
they're kind of sliding in the top of
the tank and they're going to be holding
themselves up in the water column by
pressing their feet to opposite sides of
the tank or putting them on the outside
the top rim and they'll kind of hold
them themselves with their core strain
kind of up in the water column to do the
work they need to do so we're focusing
on the algae that's growing on the
window and the plant leaves and then
also the detritus that's building up in
the tanks and that can be fals from fish
or leftover food the team goes into the
dive with a few core tools a scrub brush
trimming tools and a fine plastic
scraper to clean algae off the windows
the most painstaking part for the
aquarists in this tank is cleaning out
the beard algae so it is so annoying and
it is something that we tediously tried
to keep under control so you're seeing
these little kind of a black Puffs
that's what she's targeting right now
when she's scraping it off and
immediately removing it from the system
cuz it will just spread over
everything the divers use a gravity
siphon to clean out the loose debris
that's settled in the gravel this isn't
powered by electricity it relies solely
on gravity to suction up and separate
the waste from the
gravel algae covering everything doesn't
look great but it also can cause
problems for your fish so algae blooms
in the wild can kind of take the oxygen
that the fish need out of the system so
it can cause some harm for them that
way all the waste and debris from each
of these cleanings ends up here this is
cleaned out every 3 to 4 months to
ensure the Basin doesn't overflow it
doesn't create water quality issues and
all the systems continue to run smoothly
as you can see we've got just piles of
poop and debris and extra food stuff
that didn't get digested properly stuff
that didn't get eaten got pulled into
filtration most of it is just animal
waste there is a little bit of sand
probably about 10 5 gallon buckets or so
the equipment we'll use to clean the
Basin is a fire house and a snow shovel
cleaning this space takes roughly 2 to 3
hours and is done in stages they'll
remove the poop clean the floors and
then shovel all the sand out
once we've gotten the sand out then
we'll go around and inspect the walls
make sure there's no cracks make sure
the waterproofing is still good so where
all the discoloration happens is about
where the Basin gets roughly 55 to
60,000 gallons to a full Basin but other
than being gross the hardest part is
definitely getting the sand out just cuz
we got to lift it 25 ft in the air so we
really only want to fill them about half
full um if they were to get too full
they might Splash now and they're also
just really
heavy once this Basin is full we will
then recirculate all this water and
clean this water to reuse it for top off
water for our ocean Voyager exhibit
after the recovery all this water is
Crystal
Clean next we head to Niagara Falls
where special teams show us how they
remove dangerous rocks and maintain the
trails for visitors
safety this Jagged sheet of rock is
hanging
200 ft above a walking trail next to the
Niagara
River it's already loose and if it falls
it could mean Serious injury to hikers
on the path
below that's where the Rope access team
comes in if they do their job just right
most of Niagara Fall's 9 million yearly
visitors will never even know they were
here first jump of the
am I scared am I scared I have a healthy
respect that's
all this Cliff is located at Devil's
Hole State Park roughly 4 miles north of
Niagara Falls team members like Andy and
Christian will scale the cliff and
maintain the crew's gear later Jake will
clear dislodged rocks from the trail
those rocks were to fall naturally
there's nothing stopping them from
coming and just plowing through somebody
that's on the trail so very necessary
work but we do here and you can see here
all the rocks that come down they are
pretty sizable and could cause some
damage he me it's a dangerous job
dehydration injury and inclement weather
are just some of the risks thunderstorms
are forecast today so the team is on
high alert for signs of lightning which
would endanger the
crew we won't work in lightning that's
about
it we're going to have fun you know
usually when we show this to people they
say they didn't even know this existed
there are 12 members of today's crew
four supervisors including Andy and
eight
technicians today their goal is to clear
this entire section of the cliff their
day begins at 700 a.m. at the
maintenance shop where the team packs a
variety of gear into vehicles to take it
to the access point above the trail see
the fun thing about this is that I don't
actually jump with them every day so
today will be uh one of the days I jump
with them which is good cuz I've been
wanting to do this for a while these are
the guys who who do it every single day
and they're really really good at
it after a short 10-minute Drive the
team arrives at the access point and
begins gearing
up I guess we can start with the p
resistance this is our climbing harness
it's a class three harness um and it's
called that because of the shoulder
straps the shoulder straps prevent
climbers from slipping out of the
harness if they accidentally turn upside
down and the seat balances their body
weight so that blood flow to their legs
isn't restricted Comfort is also of the
utmost importance as climbers can be
suspended for more than 2 hours at a
time this device here is our bar rack
this is what we use to repel it's a
pretty old school
device we have a lot of mud and and grit
and when the ropes get wet they swell so
there's not a lot of moving Parts it's
all friction so that's our descent
device all
right pretty much all ready to go here
no one cares about me everyone says
Andie just take care of
yourself so what they're talking about
is some some guys have a uh a rope
pandel watching their line and then some
of us are on what we call an ASAP which
is this this is your backup device and
so I'm just fuling control of all of my
my my descent so I can actually step
over the edge
now
first jump of the
day am I scared am I scared I have a
healthy respect that's
all the crew is really close you know we
joke around a lot but when it is time to
actually go over the edge and do work
you know we kind of call that game time
because it is you know you need to take
it seriously cuz there's a lot of risks
involved this program that we're part of
has been going on since about the 19 30s
and about the whole time they've been
using pipe holes there's a lot of
utility with this this is made out of
solid fiberglass here so if it gets into
the the cliff this can Flex a lot um you
can use this to position yourself on the
wall and then you can use this to you
know gently remove debris you know you
can grab stuff with the hook gently pull
it out it can fit into cracks and then
you can get leverage that
way one of the things that makes
removing these rocks especially
challenging is that these clips undergo
something called differential erosion
which means that areas of the cliff
erode at different rates layers of shale
rock located lower on the cliff side
wear away more quickly than the layer of
dolomite rock at the top that leaves
large unstable chunks of rock sometimes
the size of an SUV hanging at the
Cliff's Edge the crew uses a controlled
swing to gain access to material beneath
overhangs to do this they push
themselves away from the wall with their
to maintain that controlled
[Music]
movement these are softball shin pads
and they work really really well for
what we do you try not to knee the wall
but sometimes for stability purposes you
know you you can't really help it we all
try to wear steel toe or some sort of
composite toe the rocks are hard you
know you can't always Dodge a rock when
you're moving so you know having
something like that to keep yourself
safe is is 100% necessary
[Music]
it's 10: a.m. the crew is only about 2/3
of the way through their climb when the
one thing they're worried about happens
a
storm copy looks like we might have a
wall yeah I'm going to head back let's
head back the crew hears Thunder and
spots lightning as they are on the cliff
side they need to stop working
immediately
that will end their progress for
today so today we actually had to cut it
short we have metal pipe PES in our hand
we got a lot of metal gear on us so we
just try to get out of there as quickly
as as we could anything that's going to
pose a hazard to the employees then we
just stop the crew had only been working
on the 200t cliff side for less than an
hour when the storm began on a typical
day it could take the crew up to 3 hours
to clear a whole section when they're
able to resume the they'll finish
removing rocks from the lower section of
the cliff and then stabilize the slope
side with wire meshing this is the the
primary um part of our work here that
we're going to try and clear this all
out so we can essentially have an open
hiking trail here again and it's going
to take a good bit of work and a good
bit of time to get this cleared out to
be safe for us to open it
again back at the shop the crew does
paperwork and washes their gear there's
actually a lot of paperwork required
with all this stuff and then so just
keeping their gear
clean you can kind of see from my shirt
I'm I'm filthy from one junk today and
you know if this is how I look our gear
is even
worse so soie water helps break it and
like lift the dirt um using a toothbrush
too to get in there and then using an
air compressor to spray any of the soap
and and uh dirt that's in there and then
we have a lubricant too when it's dry to
get in there and it's uh prevents rust
and
corrosion after the Rope access team has
made some progress it's time to start
clearing the rocks from the walking
paths below this is where the gorge crew
comes
in we take care of about seven trails in
total within the gorge itself and then
two up top on the top side now we are in
the process of cleaning the trail and
rebuilding it we've already come down
cleared the loose debris off the trail
and then started staging to get ready
for the bigger jobs ahead one of those
jobs includes a specialized
stabilization technique to ensure the
slope side is
secure so down here to fix these Trails
we use game baskets it's a 6t x 3T Cube
that is made of wire meshing and what
you do is you dig them down place them
within the trail or wherever you need
them and then you add Rock to the inside
so that the Rock weighs it down a job
like this can take a week or two but if
we have a good day where we're really
rocking and getting stuff done it can be
a maybe a 3 to 4 day job at this Mount
right here if all andrw deck I'd like to
see hopefully by the end of the summer
uh we get a majority of it taken out and
then we have to put in some uh
stabilization techniques to help build
the trail back up so I could definitely
see us working into the fall and if I
had to make a guess it'll probably be
open next
summer I think if you're going to do
this kind of work at the core you have
to enjoy working Outdoors you get see
special things that people don't see
plants and animals like the landscape
the work that you do it's really hard
but then you're helping keep the park
safe you make a meaningful difference if
you're just a parked user you might not
even realize we were ever there and
that's kind of the
point this is Mac he specializes in
cleaning the homes of people with
hoarding dis disorder and is used to
waiting through heaping piles of
clutter but this job presents an
unusually large challenge ma will be
cleaning a six-bedroom home in Illinois
and it's the biggest he's ever tackled
this is just a
nightmare uh I mean we're fighting food
from
2013 we've got paint cans that I no
longer have the strength to
carry MAC often cleans solo and does
much of this work free of charge but
this job is so daunting that he's
invited two other cleaners to join him
over the next 3 days they'll work
together to declutter and clean as many
rooms as
possible normally uh I'm dealing with a
totally different type of cleaning in
other hoarder houses I'm dealing with a
lot of insects and mouse droppings and
pet urine and just a lot of stuff that
you definitely want to have PPE on in
order to even enter the house this one
was just piles upon piles of stuff it's
the most stuff that I've ever taken out
of a
house this house belongs to a family of
four who declined to appear on camera
due to privacy reasons one of the family
members is believed to be living with
hoarding disorder although he's awaiting
an official diagnosis but even with
treatment experts say relapses can occur
this is the fourth time cleaners have
worked extensively to de to this home
the last attempt was 5 years ago rooms
in hoarder houses we will often find
rooms that have never been entered in a
decade and one of the reasons that
happens and it's really common is you
have a room that no longer has a purpose
so in this room it's the living room and
the purpose is to watch TV and to relax
if a room loses that purpose because
they start piling things up then the
purpose of the room becomes this is
where we throw all of our stuff this
place is not what I'd consider a hazard
or a biohazard it's a hazard for
tripping and it's a hazard for fire cuz
they've got an open fireplace in here
and they've got so much clutter that it
becomes a danger boing is defined as
persistent difficulty discarding or
parting with possessions regardless of
their actual value it's estimated that
somewhere between two and 4% of the
worldwide population have hoarding
disorder it's only day one of this
ambitious project but when Mac and his
team arrive at the house they discover
things already aren't going as planned
so they have cleaned a bunch of stuff
before we got here which normally I
wouldn't like I wanted the big mess and
I wanted to be able to go through the
whole house and make it pretty myself
this is I think a 30 yard dumpster they
filled two of these already over the top
and we're getting ready to fill the
third one if we had more time we would
probably f fill 10 of these from this
house so even though I'm a little
disappointed I'm really thankful that
they did have the help MC and's team
plan to start on what's typically the
hardest room to clean the kitchen
they'll need to pay special attention to
this space to ensure it's sanitary
enough for handling
food then they'll move on to the rooms
on the main level of the house and
finally tackle the basement which hasn't
been entered in 3 years the key tools
Mac and his team use are an mif fire to
cut through grease a homemade allpurpose
cleaner scouring pads and razor blade
scrapers so when people asking why this
job takes so long because we have to
check everything like if it's expired or
not or still good
no get you okay NOP a big no for the old
pancakes
no beer we never waste any beer no
[Music]
no holy crap that was a
lot yeah that's pushing an easy 200
lb Max says the biggest challenge of
cleaning a house like this is knowing
what to keep and what to throw
away there are a lot of people who will
say you're fine to throw away absolutely
everything but they don't really mean
that they mean you can throw away the
junk but you have to decipher what's
junk and what's not there's also the
urge to throw away large armfuls of
stuff and most of the time there's going
to be some stuff underneath it that's
important all right I got one counter
done I'm done beautiful back to the
hotel although cleaning the home will
make it safer and more livable it can be
distressing for people people with
hoarding disorder to see their space
transformed people who hoard tend to
have a deep connection with their
objects and removing them can create an
experience of loss which is one of the
major contributors of hoarding behaviors
he's going to come home to a very very
dramatic change and it's going to be a
shock to him and even though most people
will come home and see the change and
think oh my God this is so great you've
cleaned my house he's probably not going
to feel that
way
as day one comes to a close Mac and the
team have finished most of the kitchen
which they will continue to clean for
the next 2 days on day two Barbie and
Bonnie will also tackle the sun room and
living room while Mac Ventures into the
basement I'm going to go down to that
basement and do as much as I can on the
basement today um that is going to
completely wear me out if I can get that
out of the way today then that means
tomorrow we can do things like the
dining room and uh get this floor
done I'm going to attempt to tackle this
area this whole area there's this part
of the basement there is a room to my
left and there's a room over here and
they all look like what's behind me this
is going to be extremely difficult
because there is a lot of things that
need to be kept Mac discovers an
abundance of stockpiled food and
supplies including countless jugs of
water jars of marinara sauce bottles of
hydrogen peroxide and 5 gallon
containers filled with something unusual
all these 5 gallon buckets those are all
filled with
food yeah I thought they were paint kind
like that one says macaroni and
spaghetti or something so I'm just going
to stack them all together and they want
to keep do you think it's still good
probably not people can inherit
characteristics from their parents that
make them more likely to develop
hoarding behaviors grief and loss can
also contribute to this over the years
Mac has noticed patterns in the kinds of
items he finds while cleaning they Stack
Up air filters and medication and
antibiotics and hydrogen peroxide and
alcohol and all of them are unopened and
all of them are there just in case and
they just keep building and building as
Mac continues sorting through jugs of
water and medical supplies he stumbles
on one ice in particular he's learned to
never throw away I've thrown away shells
twice and in both occasions people were
like have you seen a big bag of shells
that was when we went to Myrtle Beach or
Florida or whatever on a family trip but
they're never displayed as a collection
they're just stuffed in a bag in some
random spot but I've learned over time
that shells are always a momentto for
somebody unless they got their house
Infested by clams in which case they're
good you have much of what Mac finds in
the basement needs to be lugged upstairs
to the dumpsters and so many trips up
and down the stairs with heavy bags is
starting to take its toll right now my
neck is just throbbing and my right arm
I'm pretty sure is injured I have to be
super careful today on what I lift and
how I lift it and how much I lift it's a
little scary because uh if I tweak my
back anymore I'm out of the picture and
I don't want that to happen back
upstairs Barbie and Bonnie are finishing
the kitchen and starting on the living
room and the sun
room I wish I had time to clean all of
this
priorities the owner used to sit out in
the sunro every morning and to have you
know scrambled eggs and toast and coffee
and just she likes to bead and I like
knowing those details about the owner
because it lets us know where
emotionally this cleanup is going to
affect them in a positive way as the
crew begins to wrap up for the day the
wife of the person suspected to be
living with hoarding disorder becomes
emotional at the sight of the progress
they've made she was on the second floor
of the house looking over the banister
and just seeing what Barbie had
accomplished and she wasn't even fully
done with the room uh she broke down in
tears just being able to see the floor
again so if your partner has boarding
disorder there is a resentment and a
frustration and an anger that builds up
and then finally there's a release point
where everything just comes out and
that's what happened there she's um very
happy to see it opened up uh she's been
in the house for 13 years today's work
was way more exhausting than yesterday
it's a different type of cleaning though
because it's less it takes less of your
mind to do it I guess I'm not really
looking at having to sanitize and to get
out tiny little stains I'm just looking
to get things out of people's way and so
it takes less mental effort but man it
takes a lot more physical
effort It's the final day of the crew's
3-day cleanup and this is their last
chance to organize and declutter as much
of the main floor as possible this is
the day where we have to be basically on
our game and moving quickly we're
wrapping up the kitchen we have a dining
room which is just stuff that needs to
be
moved despite the exhaustion Mac is
experiencing he returns to the basement
and makes another
Discovery God it's like old rotten
garden
seeds and
uh they're not dangerous but they smell
really bad garden seeds when they go bad
smell like raw sewage you have to
breathe through your mouth when you're
putting it in otherwise it'll it'll make
you
nauseous you'll be able to see the story
unfold as you go through layer after
layer of old stuff the deeper you go
into a horde that's where you start
finding the really rotten stuff and so
it always gets worse before it gets
better excessive acquisition occurs in
the vast majority of cases often times
these items are on sale and therefore
are bought in large
amounts so instead of just getting one
they see the deal and they'll get 20 but
there's even in a big house like this
there's not room to put them all so
you've got this giant pile of shop
lights and you're probably going to find
that with everything from craft supplies
to just random kind of
stuff Night Lights there's an entire
rack of Night Lights what's really
frustrating about this is there's so
much stuff that's necessary and has
legitimate actual use that's actually
real really rare for a hoarder house at
the end of day three the crew has
successfully cleaned the kitchen sun
room living room dining room and
basement and they've removed enough
stuff to fill build three 30 yard
dumpsters to the brim we're almost done
now compared to other hoarder houses
it's just me with three of us working
here in order to get the entire house
every single room top to bottom clean we
would have needed a crew of probably 10
plus people for at least 2 weeks after
Mac and his team leave the family will
finish cleaning the remaining rooms
they'll also hire help to maintain the
home I like seeing a house that is so
covered up with stuff that whenever you
get all of it put away and where it goes
and you get everything cleaned up seeing
the house as it was intended to be seen
is really a cool thing to me and I think
that's part of my my brain that thinks
of rooms like jigsaw puzzles but what
keeps me doing it I think is more the
stress relief that you see happen on the
owner of the house you can see the
stress come off of them at the very end
whenever you leave this one was just
exhausting in every measure just because
of the sheer amount of stuff but it's
it's worth it especially whenever we get
to look around the house and say holy
crap we did that we all did
that
now we travel to the UK where oie
pickles the owner of eye doctor shows us
how he cleans the dirtiest
iPhones I think the most difficult part
of cleaning an iPhone is just knowing
that you're touching somebody else's
Grime and mock it's disgusting really
when you think about
it I can already see that we've got
quite a lot of gunk in the ear speaker
and the speaker grills so hopefully
there'll be some gunk in there to see
and we can give it a real good clean out
as
well lint builds up from inside
somebody's pocket and over time when the
charging ca's inserted taken out
reinserted all that happens is it just
compacts into the charge port itself and
leaves this sort of mess behind and all
this lint over time it just compacts
every time you put it on charge it just
compacts deep down into the port
when you start noticing the Earp can
becomes quiet the microphone people
can't hear you or it's not charging
correctly you might have to stand on
your head and do a back flip just to
make it charge that's probably when you
need to start thinking about cleaning
out that charge port or the a
speaker I'm using this little BGA
scraper which is typically designed for
scraping the uh resin overfill or
underfill from logic boards but it
doubles up as a really really really
useful tool for cleaning out these
charging
ports the stuff what we usually find in
the charging ports and crevices of the
phone is mostly either Pocket Gun or
fluff from the bottom of handbags I mean
I'm not a forensic scientist but I'm
going to guess there is dog
a dust fluff I I don't really know how
to describe the
uh the F what in there other things that
we found in the phones rice is quite
common when phones have become water
damaged because they'll stick the phone
in rice that doesn't work by the way we
did find some weed in one of them and it
looked like they must have been keeping
the stash in the pocket and it the same
thing again there was weed inside the
charge
port so this iPhone 7 is coming for a
battery replacement and you as you can
see it's absolutely full of dust lint
hair wood chip feathers you name it it's
in this phone well I can see that the
screen's been replaced before I think
they've probably just never replaced the
dust seal what's on there this is really
common because believe it or not not
many repair places will replace that
dust and moisture seal the best way to
clean something like this out is to get
all the thick stuff probably with the
dust
blower there is definitely a risk that
this dust could cause a short circuit on
the on the motherboard it's going to put
lots of strain on peripheral Hardware
like the loud speaker it's going to be
quiet the vibration motor is not going
to work very well or you're going to get
funny sounds from the vibration motor a
lot of people think that it's just for
moisture it keeps a seal between the
screen and the chassis of the phone
which out of the factory is designed so
that it's sealed away from elements like
dust and
dirt ear speaker cleaning is one of the
things what we get all the time where
somebody's phone's really
quiet 10 to 20% of the phones what we
get in need cleaning
out the easiest way to clean out an
iPhone ear speaker is using some
isopropyl alcohol the customer last for
a ear speaker replacing but in reality
it just needs cleaning out and even if
we did replace the ear speaker it
probably would still be quiet because
that mesh is just bummed up and gunked
up then we loosen up the gunk with a
toothbrush make sure that it's not the
toothbrush that you've used this morning
to brush your teeth and then we play
this sound which plays a 165 htz sound
which acts as a sort of ultrasonic
cleaner for the most part I think that
the most common thing that gets in ear
speaker is probably ear
[Music]
wax I don't really want to think about
what else it could be what's getting in
there because it's yeah it's
gross
we use two different types of brushes I
for for the softer brush we use a
toothbrush and then a slightly more
stiff one is this small horse hair brush
the vibrations act as an agitator and it
it loosens the dirt what's in those tiny
little gaps in the ear
speaker
so the cloth over the speaker we add a
little bit of alcohol onto there and the
way that that works is just adding a
finer layer of cleaning stuff just to
get any remaining bits of dust out of
[Music]
there so for this one it's a iPhone 11
Pro and it's got a little bit of gunk in
the speaker Grill at the bottom which
would make the phone pretty quiet this
is very similar to what gets built up
inside the charge port it's just pocket
Gunk the best tool for this one is the
shop pointed BGA scraper
again the debris in these holes will
often look like a brownie sort of beige
color whereas the actual speakers are
black so you'll know that you've got it
in
there
than
I sort of got involved with fixing
friends and Family's phones sorting out
technical problems for them and once I I
started learning about phone repair I
just got deeper and deeper into it it's
like a rabbit hole and I just got fully
sucked down
it we receive about 20 iPhones per week
in the post and we probably take in from
walk-in customers between 5 and 15
phones a
day you get lots of instances where
somebody might bring a phone in and it
might be a minor thing and they say oh
look my phone's completely dead and it's
it's it's really good to see people very
happy once you've repaired their
devices back in the US Trey zippa shows
us how to properly clean forgotten
veterans gravestones covered with moss
and
algae so I get a lot of questions about
why are these Stones so dirty this is
not dirt these are living organisms
these are plants the more polished the
stone the less surface area there is for
the biological organisms to adhere to
the stone and so the reason why we use
this quinary ammonium compound is this
kills them so these things are natural
in nature you're going to find in the
South especially it's not just growing
on rooftops it's also growing on our
headstones my name is Trey Zipperer I'm
the founder of B Memorial Day a non
profit organization dedicated to the
cleaning of all veteran headstones by
Memorial Day in
perpetuity so this is a ground level
grave marker issued by the federal
government via the national cemetery
Administration it's a white marble
material Natural Stone it was a Gunners
mate GM third class US Navy I don't
think it's respectful to have a
veteran's headstone uh dirty in the
least and so we're going to clean this
headstone of this American hero who gave
his all who sacrificed unimaginable
Horrors for three and A2 years as a
prisoner of war the first thing I like
to do is I use a a uh a desk broom to
get all of the sand and and debris off
of the stone so we take our water squirt
bottle um I like the one with a little
bit bigger base on it I give it a
coating of
water cuz again these these stones are
porous so it's going to soak in this
clean water which is not going to get
down in any chemical down inside the
stone we use a cleaning agent that
contains an active ingredient known as a
quinary ammonium compound and it is
known and respected throughout historic
preservationist as the safest most
effective way to clean Natural Stone
this brush uh is made with bristles from
tampo so tampo from the agave plant is a
natural bristle that won't harm the
Natural Stone and then I want to give it
a good coating of the D2 biological
solution which is going to go to work on
this Stone very quickly you're going to
see this Stone starting to turn a bit of
an orange color and then it's going to
continue working on the stone for the
next few weeks and that stone will
become brighter and whiter and whiter uh
and you have to clean them about every 2
to three years this does a wonderful job
of getting all the growth killed on the
stone the next step is to let that soak
for about 10 minutes when I'm looking at
a headstone in a cemetery I want that
stone to be impeccably clean it doesn't
matter if it's almost clean it needs to
be clean I think the reason why some
veteran headstones become more soiled or
more covered in biological growth is
because of the polishing of the Stone
the more polished the stone the less
surface area there is for the biological
organisms to adhere to the stone and
after about 10 minutes it's not that
hard to get the material off the stone
with a a soft bristle natural bristle
brush
then you can get into the etchings with
a toothbrush to get into the real nooks
and crannies of things
sometimes and the final step of honoring
a veteran of our past is to place an
American flag at their grave this is
known as a grave flag this particular
grave has already had an American Legion
flag holder placed at the grave and
there's a spot in the back of them for
the flag stick to just stick right down
into
it my vision of B Memorial Day is this
one day in the near future we'll have a
volunteer assigned to every Veteran's
grave in America no matter where that
veteran is buried no matter what
cemetery they're in
so to tell you a little bit about why
this happens these are living organisms
these are plants growing on the stone
whether they're algae or lyans or
mold uh mildew and so the reason why we
use this quinary ammonium compound is
this kills them so these things are
natural in nature you're going to find
in the South especially we have this
black mold on all of our our concrete
tile roof
and it's not just growing on rooftops
it's also growing on our
headstones I think it's important that
we don't lose the stories of our veteran
Heroes of the past because they truly
are forgotten their stories are are
disappearing because when they pass away
and the people who knew them pass away
they're stories are pretty much gone
forever so now we're uh going to start
on the etchings I start with the cross
at the top and work my way down just
each letter uh these are etched into the
marble as compared to the early veteran
headstones were B known as bash relief
where the letters were basically
sticking out they removed the material
around the letters so the letters became
kind of like
three-dimensional the material that
grows inside these Stones it's a
combination of things fixed in there and
also there's little Ledges so to speak
where when the wind blows the pollen
Falls all different types of things will
just get wedged and just build up in
these
etchings grave Flags measure 8 in by 12
in but I would rather have a flag then
no flag so if you can't find an 8 by 12
that doesn't mean you can't place a flag
at the grave the person at a Podium
speaking for example the American flag
is to their right so in this case we
have uh a headstone of American veterans
so as the veterans looking at you the
flag needs to be to his or her right you
want to get as close to the stone as you
can without marring the stone with your
Mallet because when the weat eaters and
other types of Maintenance equipment
comes through you don't want them
hitting your flag holder
the way that I research the veterans
buried beneath the veteran headstones
that I clean uh is by using the internet
first and I go to certain sources that I
know uh contain content such as find a
grave.com there's a several different
websites like that and by looking into
those different
databases and different family trees on
ancestry.com you can start to put
together the story of a veteran and
every now and then you just get
something that's amazing and insightful
that you didn't
anticipate this is a application for
headstone or marker uh for a uh deceased
American Veteran uh the family members
would have to complete this application
in order to choose what style of Veteran
headstone that they wanted for their
loved one and this particular
application is for Robert S Lewis
prepared by his father and this is where
the store story of his sacrifice uh
became
apparent this man was a sergeant
Sergeant shadman was a top turret Gunner
fire in the cockpit could not see if he
got out I saw Sergeant shadman reaching
for a parachute I do not believe he
could have gotten out alive because the
plane broke apart where he was last seen
when they were attacked they were flying
at 24,000 ft Sergeant shadman was up in
the top turret uh he was a Gunner and he
was trying to get out out of that top
turet as the plane was tumbling to the
ground his death's date says September
12th 1944 but there's evidence to
suggest that he did in fact get out of
that aircraft and he did reach the
ground alive because there's a hospital
admission record of him in September
1944 we don't know what day that he died
but his mother uh applied for his
veteran headstone with a death date of
September
23rd in your local cemeteries there are
Local Heroes whose graves are in really
bad condition and it's pretty sad that a
man or a woman gives their life for our
country and then they're forgotten in
the cemetery and their headstone can't
even be read because there's so much
biological filth on it there are people
in America who care about veteran Graves
they just don't know what's happening
out here so I want to bring this story
to them so that they know that in your
local cemeteries there are Local Heroes
whose graves are in really bad condition
so if this is something that speaks to
your heart I encourage you to get out in
your local Cemetery see for yourself if
there's veteran headstones in need of
cleaning in your local area and take the
initiative to do something about
[Music]
it this is a rare Persian rug that's
appraised at an estimated
,500 and it's about to get its first
cleaning in more than two decades Cades
it's a delicate job and not just because
this antique is so valuable it's also a
family heirloom and the clients are
trusting the team at rosatti rugs to
deep clean it carefully the goal is to
remove the accumulation of dirt and
stains without harming the rug's
coloring Ali Rosati inspects the fibers
carefully to determine how the rug was
originally dyed this key detail will
determine how he'll complete the job
without causing any damage so his
clients can continue to pass down this
treasure for Generations so my client's
aunt had this rug for about 20 years and
she was very hesitant to have it clean
because she was afraid that it would get
ruined I know this is a 1940s rug
because they used vegetable dyes in
comparison to a 1960s Tes like this one
here there's a specific process to
cleaning vegetable Dy rugs I know that I
can use a deep wash because the dyes
won't run this is the pool that we have
the rugs clean clean and we have a drain
right here it's built on an angle so
that when we put a rug on either side
the water will just go right through
directly into the
drain one of arie's team members Begins
the cleaning process by applying
Browning treatment to the stains this
works to remove tannin type stains like
urine fruit juice beer or soil as well
as general discoloration due to
age this 19 40 shik mashi rug has
collected stains from various family
gatherings throughout the years but
that's not all that makes this tb's rug
unique what makes it so special is not
only the technique of weave and the fine
weaving on the back but also the design
and the color combinations that are used
as well after letting the Browning
treatment sit for 15 minutes he hoses
down the rug and applies
shampoo
next he agitates the fibers with a
scrubber which loosens up the
accumulated dirt and brings it to the
surface so the scrubber or the buffer is
used to help scrub and expand the use of
the shampoo throughout the rug and it
does it in a fast and efficient way so
if you were to actually hand do this Not
only would you get tired physically but
wouldn't be as
effective Ary estimates that the
original Weaver made only a few hundred
of these rugs decades ago the coloring
also dates back to a time when Master
Weavers used different techniques this
rug is made with vegetable dyed wool
which means the coloring came from
natural materials like plants fruits or
tree bar this method is more labor
intensive which adds to the rug's value
Chrome dyes come from chemicals that are
used and boiled to create certain
certain colors Chrome dyes were used to
decrease the cost of rug weaving so in
terms of price point they are less in
comparison to rugs that have vegetable
dyes Incorporated in them as you can see
this type of a red tone is so bright you
only see that in Chrome dyes but with
vegetable dyes they're a little bit more
subtle in
comparison the transition from vegetable
dyes to Chrome dyes in the mid 20th
century brought about a new era in rug
making Chrome dyes offered a wider and
more affordable range of Hues which
revolutionized the industry but the
legacy of those early Persian rug makers
is still visible today in rugs like this
which is why it's so important to
preserve it the team member rinses the
rug and pushes a squeegee across each
section to remove excess water he
repeats this step several times
throughout the cleaning process to
remove as much water as possible
he runs the scrubber across the rug
again to loosen any remaining dirt and
then uses the extractor to lift the
stains and remove
moisture the extractor actually has two
purposes you can one just use it as a
vacuum you just place it on the rug and
you start pulling it towards your
direction and it starts extracting the
water out so that the rug gets to dry
faster also it has another feature where
if you press on the lever not only will
it extract water but it'll expel hot
water at the same time and those are
great for taking away stains because you
could do that multiple times on a
certain
area all the rugs are heated to a high
temperature of I'd say about 90° on
average and they're hung right here the
rug must be completely dry before moving
on to the next step if not the excess
moisture can lead to mold and Mild you
two factors that can deteriorate the
fibers in the rug we'll go inside of the
drawing room and we'll examine it and
touch the pile of the rug the fringes
and the other aspects of the rug to see
if it's still moist or not if we feel it
is we'll keep it in there the room is dy
to a very high temperature and just
having all the fans and dehumidifiers
usually having a rug in there for about
a day would completely dry it
out the quality of Wee on tabes rugs is
based on something called Raj which
counts the number of linear knots every
7 cm
which is roughly 2 and 1/2 in the higher
the rage the higher the quality which
also makes a rug more valuable so in
today's market I would estimate this
value around $112,500 you have these
lines that are showing on the back side
of the rug and when you look at those
lines you'll be able to actually count
how many knots are in between each line
and so this specific rug is 50 r on a
lower quality tiis you'll have a 20 rag
this is actually a lower quality Tipper
you can see how big the knots are in
comparison to this Ru here these knots
are a lot more tight this is around that
20 rag that I had mentioned earlier and
then you have the 50 rag which is a more
higher quality 60 rag would be very
exceptional and then you'll have like 80
or 90 rad which are extremely rare to
find and those type of rugs take close
to 10 years years to make but this typee
of a caliber I'd say in terms of Rarity
on a scale of 1 to 10 it would be a
seven so when you look at the different
color combinations and designs that are
used in this rug it seems like there's a
lot of religious symbolism going on and
that makes sense because she Mash was a
religious man within his region and the
predominant use of green is of Islamic
religious significance because green was
the prophet Muhammad's favorite color
I've grown up with Persian rugs in my
home and there's a lot of deep cultural
significance to Persian rugs and the
history behind it so I feel very akin to
my culture being in this
industry the rug looks magnificent it's
much brighter than it was before and the
majority of the stains have been removed
there are a lot of other people in this
industry that really don't put their
heart into it they just clock in and
clock out but each rug is a portion of a
person's home and I take that
responsibility to heart that when they
bring the rug to me they're bringing a
part of their home into my life for me
to take care
[Music]
of